all right let's talk about this big news
man The Daily Mail reports FBI deep
State team of 80 people regularly handed
Twitter lists of people to ban including
actor Billy Baldwin and satire accounts
new Trove of musk's Twitter files reveal
Matt Tybee posted a new Trove of Twitter
documents on Friday they show emails
from FBI officials requesting bans on
Twitter users how dare they go after
Billy Baldwin that's the most shocking
thing of all so here's here's one of the
emails it's uh from what from fbi.gov
Twitter folks please see below list of
Twitter accounts which we believe are
violating your terms of service by
disseminating false information about
the time place or manner of the upcoming
election let us know if you decide to
take any action against these accounts
based on your your uh our Tipper to you
also let us know if we need to issue a
preservation letter as we intend to
serve legal process for these accounts
thanks for your consideration there's
something that I found really
interesting in this latest release and
it was that Matt taiibi goes on to say
he he had an FBI agent reach out to him
who told him that most companies deal
with stuff like this with the FBI but
they're adversarial he said T-Mobile is
absolutely adversarial the FBI agent
said that when they send a request to
T-Mobile and get it wrong T-Mobile
employs a leak the communications
causing problems for the FBI that's the
way to do it I like me these T-Mobile
people you know there you go push back
on this stuff but look at what we got
here I mean this is this is amazing some
of these emails are just straight up
like thank you for your patience as our
team assessed the uh I'm sorry that's
from Twitter some of these emails like
one of them was just like please see
these accounts that need to be removed
and then it's like okay then they come
back and they're basically like yep we
did what you asked thanks uh thanks boss
that's uh this is the current state of
our elections I suppose the scary thing
with all of this is that
80 FBI agents
shutting down jokes satire and what they
deem to be misinformation
it's wild
at the same time that how many other
things were they missing because they
had this many FBI agents looking at
jokes and satire on Twitter all of the
child trafficking right exactly
we've got a crisis happening at the
border and they weren't missing that
they chose not to do anything about it
they prioritized the satire over content
that was dangerous well they did a
little bit more than that let's be
honest here with the activities of the
FBI for 30 years when victims were
coming to them they're just you know
ignoring it but there was 13 year old
children coming to Twitter being like
hey there's an adult video of me here on
this platform please remove it Twitter
said no that video got 160 000 views 2
000 retweets and Twitter after they
verified the identification they're like
yeah we're not just going to do anything
about it as they were in constant
contact with the FBI I mean are you are
you kidding me and and the FBI
micromanaging our political discourse is
not a surprise here they're doing this
not just with Twitter they're probably
doing this with YouTube they're probably
doing this with Facebook book A lot of
these coordinated attacks especially
when it came to censorships were with a
lot of platforms acting together in
unison many instances and for years I've
been screaming these are not private
platforms there was always a debate a
couple years ago saying they could do
what they want they they they're a
private organization this is what
capitalism is all about and I was
screaming off the top of my head no this
is not capitalism this is the government
essentially uh creating a KGB like
political Purge on the line destroying
political speech here orchestrated by
top levels of people within the
government this has nothing to do with
private entities this is your tax
dollars being used to censor your speech
your humor your comedy and who would
have thought the FBI doesn't have a
sense of humor huh yeah and I think you
know um uh you said it and I think it's
it's so true people so often say um well
I mean we already knew that this was
going on so what's the big deal and but
there is it takes a certain level of
sheer arrogance to say we're going to
accuse the other side of doing all of
these things we're going to accuse them
of Russian collusion we're going to
spend two years and millions of taxpayer
dollars to look into this you know
totally bogus thing meanwhile we know
that this is what we're actually doing
we just don't think that they're ever
going to find out because we control
everything yep so while for the longest
time child abuse videos are on Twitter
you've got an FBI agent sitting there in
his van you know eating a bag of Cheetos
and he's like scrolling through Twitter
looking at all the exploitation videos
like and then he sees a guy whose name
is ultramaga wangamaga hat saying don't
forget to vote trumpet
she texts Twitter immediately like get
it off get it off I mean I'd like to
believe that's an exaggeration but I'm
it probably actually what happened yeah
I mean what else what else do you think
happened here they they were giving out
almost daily reports of individuals that
they wanted censored by by them because
of Comedy because of humor because of
satire I mean how more egregious do you
have to get I mean this is I mean making
people laugh is not a threat against
National Security unless you're the FBI
and you see that as a threat questioning
of course mainly Authority uh so I mean
I think we're only just scratching the
surface here with these Twitter files
there's a lot more coming I think
there's a bigger FBI involvement here I
think there's definitely a lot more back
Channels with what we have seen
throughout the last few years and I
think it's not just the FBI I think
there's also other branches of the
government participating in these kind
of larger political KGB purges uh
including of course Dr fauci's team
which Elon Musk actually teased was
going to be released soon as well so I'm
very lucky I'm very much looking forward
to that myself I don't know about you
guys do you remember when they just
dropped what was at the first or second
Twitter file dump and Elon himself said
that this was a violation of the First
Amendment and people kept you know
calling back to him like that's not true
because it's just the Biden campaign
they weren't in office yet you can't
prove that and you know it was painfully
obvious to all of us who have been
paying attention that first of all when
you have a a campaign an incoming
campaign obviously they don't like lose
touch with these same Twitter contacts
that they had but you know secondly Elon
has seen behind the curtain right like
he's seen it all so of course he's going
to know more than what they've dumped
you had to expect that he was going to
come forward with confirmation of active
government you know collusion I mean
didn't Katie Hobbs wasn't their email
from the cases
yeah can you take this down well yes but
their argument was well that doesn't
count because it was just a campaign
they weren't actually part of the
government yet well what is the argument
now because that seems like oh I know
and now all of a sudden they're silent
yeah it doesn't make any sense I find
myself thinking like what recourse do
any of these people have though like are
we expecting that one day we'll get an
email from Elon Musk saying by the way
here's the evidence that you need to try
and you know if you are in a sympathetic
District get a ruling from a judge to
get some kind of compensation from
Twitter like what are the consequences
that anyone involved this will really
face realistically I think it's good
that it's coming out but I would like to
see more and I don't know how that's
pursued that's a great question to ask
but it's also important to add a
different layer to it because what
effects did this censorship have I think
we need to ask ourselves this what was
the what was the result of them
censoring political thought and
expression who was more in favor who won
who benefited off of these censorship
actions uh that's a question that I
think is pretty clear and obvious but
what extent was it done I think there
needs to be more investigations more
studies and very surprisingly Matt Gates
came out and said that there's a lot of
questions that he has for the FBI that
him and his colleagues are going to be
asking very soon in Congressional
hearings but this is just the beginning
I think we need we need a whole church
commission style hearing we need a whole
uh way just to have total transparency
of exactly what's going on here because
we still are only seeing a small portion
of it and I bet you it gets more rotten
more nasty and more seedy than we could
even imagine it at right now yeah I
agree uh especially with the
Congressional hearings because I mean if
his history has proven anything what we
heard fauci we know he committed perjury
we heard uh Jack Dorsey it seems like he
committed perjury we've got a long list
of people who seemingly commit perjury
in front of Congress and nothing really
happens to them so what are the
ramifications you go up there you lie
you go home everyone knows you're lying
and nothing happens yeah law enforcement
Society it's all it's all broken yep I
mean you look at almost every
circumstance of Street violence from the
far left unaccountable unaccount like
there's no accountability none so why
would
if conservatives don't respond in any
meaningful way
why would any cop stick his neck out why
would any member of Congress actually go
after this why would any law enforcement
agent agency actually go after this
there is no upside it's that simple you
go to any member of Congress Republican
or Democrat I shouldn't say any but most
of the Republicans you go to any law
enforcement agency and say here is
someone advocating for violence doing
something awful or committing violence
and they'll say well you know if we
arrest them antifa will show up and
firebomb the precinct if we don't we
don't got to worry about it and
conservatives won't do anything anyway
so no upside right no reason to do it
but you got it back to Blue you know
well if you don't back the blue you know
these things
listen here you little commies here
someone made a very interesting comment
uh in the chat room right now he says uh
you know you should look at Rules for
Radicals because one of the tactics
there is to ridicule uh your opponents
as being one of the most effective ways
to kind of use uh humor against your
enemies so I think this is one reason
why the FBI was going after humor and
comedy so much because they know how
effective it is because when we look at
our modern political landscape politics
is everywhere A lot of people are sick
of politics but if you could crack a
joke if you could make people laugh you
can make them think and I think this is
why we have seen the weaponization of
the Jon Stewart show we saw how popular
it was and we saw similar kind of forms
of entertainment being formed by that
probably with uh State uh you know State
Park participation and I I think this is
something that we shouldn't uh you know
because some people are going to say oh
it's just comedians don't worry about it
no this had a big effect I think on our
society more than we could expect
especially with the chilling effect
stopping other comedians from saying
that spicy joke or making that spicy
comment that stopped the discourse from
progressing in our society thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time